upstairs
okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is Peter
Richards and I'll be chairing the
meeting this evening some housekeeping
that I made to start with we're not
expecting a fire alarm so if one does go
off please follow us to the car park
over the road and we will need to check
your names off the entry list to make
sure everyone is safely out the building
so please make sure you hang around to
do that before you head off uh to your
various uh homes
um mobile phones if you could please uh
turn them to silent at the very least
preferably off I understand some people
might need to use them in emergency so
as I say silence at the very least long
as they don't disturb the flow of the
meeting I'm perfectly happy for them to
be like that
um the meeting itself is a meeting in
public it is not a public meeting so
only the people permit that excuse me
only those that have registered to speak
will be permitted to do so at the
appropriate time we will call you four
to one of the many microphones in front
of you there if you press the button on
the right it will send it red you can
see here and you will be heard
um uh we will give you your commencement
amount of time um I will be given 30
second warnings for time is up and when
we do that we'll using this noise oh my
noise doesn't work if you turn it off
we'll just give you a normal 30 seconds
because my my favorite button has been
disabled
um so there we go um okay let we've got
a packed agenda so let's go straight in
so can we have apology strap since first
of all please
yes chair we have apologies from
councilor Adam For Whom councilor off is
substituting and councilor head to
seraphin thank you very much welcome
Council Rolf um do we have any
disclosures of Interest please members
Council Kendall thank you chair
um on item four first application uh
application reference 22 03276 ful
um the it it's an iron Parish Council
for Wells more which is adjoining this
parish and I've made my views very very
plain over that's why I just cannot come
to this with an open minds I'll step
down from the committee I understand
thank you much um I'll put mine in while
we're on it so same application I'm
registered speaker most of the ward
member so I will be making myself uh
absent from the table we will look to
vote in an appropriate chairman in just
a moment once we've finished all the
apologies so councilor Perry next please
thank you chair
um I'd also like to disclose an interest
on application four I come with an open
mind but I am the prospective candidate
for wellsborn Northern rural which of
which this particular application would
fall in from the 4th of May
understood thank you very much Council
Rolf next please
uh thank you uh today I received from
pictures from Studio Spicer I think it
was Meadow Cottage did I think it was
sent to everyone it was indeed I was on
the first item as kingsmead Farm to the
one we've been talking about so you've
timed that beautifully thank you very
much councilor Dixon next please thank
you chairman uh itemmate on the agenda
which is application
22-03706 uh I shall be speaking as a
ward member on that one and therefore
excusing myself from the committee thank
you very much councilman Mills please
thanks Mr chairman on application five
on the agenda that's uh 22 forward slash
zero three six three six
forward slash ful
um I'm the County Council for this
division but uh I haven't entered it
into any discussion with so I can sit on
the table with an open mind Mr
chair good man thank you very much
councilor Harvey please
thank you Mr chairman
um item six uh I will be speaking as the
board member in relation to Middle house
darling Scott
okay thanks very much caskets did I see
you put a hand up then or is that you're
just twitching
okay no one else marvelous so just to
clear the um there is a blanket uh
disclosure on the first items the king's
mid farm that we all did receive um uh
correspondence in relation to that
including photos
um I have also and I'm going to assume
that everyone else has received the same
uh received about Meadow Cottage again
um uh I've received a series of
clippings from newspapers and pictures
and bits and pieces I'm seeing nodding
from everyone so if we could have a
blanket disclosure on that one as well
please
jolly good now as I say we are gonna
well I'll do the minutes first everyone
happy with the minutes
um from the 22nd of February yes yes I'm
seeing lots of nods good perfect
um I'll sign those later on um we of
course now need to get a chairman for
this first item I am going to be
proposing councilor Crump could I have a
second there count secondary by
councilor Parry any other proposals or
nominations no quick show hands uh yeah
everyone's happy good in that case
Council Crump come on down
foreign
I think I was voted in because this is
new technology and the other members of
the committee don't want to look forward
if so
apologies if things do go slightly wrong
um I have been chair of planning
committee before so I've got some idea
what happened
and I think we need to introduce the
officers over here to
um I might so I will let Alice have that
privilege tonight I know she's also will
be making a statement afterwards so kind
of far away honest please absolutely
thank you chairman so um to the
Chairman's right we've got Howard
Allison from Community Services Amy
Shipley the legal solicitor this evening
Amy flute planning officer as well as
the planning officers in the corner
we've got Emma Booker Stuart McIver and
marvena it's yak and I am the planning
manager this evening Alice Cosner I have
a short statement to make just to make
it clear what my role is so it is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking thank
you
and there was a method in my Madness
though is that I didn't make any
mistakes with anybody's surnames or so
with the name like Crump that's nice and
easy but so yes we'll now move on to the
first item on the agenda which is
application 22
03276 slash Fu panel and our presented
officer is Amy flute please thank you
Amy
thank you chairman just
let everybody see the presence the
presentation being shown I just want to
double check before I start
yeah great thank you I couldn't see that
there
um so the application site denoted by
the um black dot is an existing
agricultural building the application
site is in an open Countryside location
the site is for edged red the site is
served by an existing access childcare
Conservation Area is to the north of the
site and permission is sought to remove
the agricultural building and create two
dwellings
the building which is the subject of
this application is starred the site is
in the foreground of a former
traditional Farmstead which has a
courtyard Arrangement and that's
currently undergoing conversion to
residential and some and there are some
other Residential Properties
um to the South as well
the site has extant class Q approval to
convert the existing Barn into free
dwellings the class key site layouts
under pre-denovations can be seen on the
left and by comparison the proposed
layout can be seen on the right hand
side which shows the proposed built form
for this proposal to create two detached
dwellings
the proposed elevations and floor plans
can now be seen the dwellings will be
two-story with a large single-story flat
roofed area and a Gable feature which
will house the two-story element the
dwellings will be constructed from Red
Brick Timber cladding tile and Sedum
Reeves and have three bedrooms
this image is taken from Stratford Road
looking towards the site in a
northwesterly direction the site is
screened by existing Conifer trees which
are to be removed and copper Heath the
nearest adjoining property can also be
seen
and this image shows the existing Barn
which is proposed to be demolished and
the conifers which are in in the
background are also to be removed
this image is looking from the site in a
southerly direction and shows the
relationship between the existing barn
and the adjoining property copper Heath
the access to into the um Farmstead
Courtyard can also be seen
and these are some images of the
adjoining Courtyard and to show the
former Farmstead buildings
somehow they have been converted and
some are
um obviously being converted further
into residential
and finally this image is the former I'm
sorry this image is the view looking
back towards the existing Barn from
um the
um access road to the to the wider
agricult former agricultural farmstead
so chairman
um it is considered that the proposal is
more harmful than the extant class queue
as a result of its design and the
proposal
um would result in landscaping character
harm um in this open Countryside
location the recommendation is to refuse
the application subject to the reasons
as detailed within the report and also
please note some updates on the update
sheet thank you
thank you Amy I was just going to
mention the update see what you beat me
to Sir hopefully members have read that
the amended reason for a refusal too
right we will now move on to our first
speaker on this item which is Mr Elliot
Goodall
if he is here yes thank you
have fun
Microsoft
well you've got three minutes
uh would you like a warning go with
about 30 seconds or are you okay
yep
that's some more more technology I've
got to play with there as well so
that'll be fun
good evening my name is Elliot Goodall
I'm an architect and have been working
with the applicant on this site since
2016. during this time we have worked
closely with the planning department to
successfully seek permission and
sensitively convert the traditional 18th
century Bic buildings that formed the
core of the former agriculture unit
known as Kingsley Farm
um we hope in time that the site can be
considered for local Awards
based on the quality of the conversions
the 18th century former Farm unit is
arranged around two interjoining
Courtyards and maintaining that setting
the buildings now form seven dwellings
that provide a mix of two three and four
bedroom homes with views out over the
surrounding childcare Parkland and
Countryside
the application before you is for the
construction of two three-bedroom homes
in lieu of three two-bedroom homes as
approved under the class queue
um application the existing building
subject of that permission sits away
from the main group and does not form
part of the traditional Courtyard
arrangement
the class key approval notice conditions
the removal of the existing mature
Conifer bout which sits to the east
and currently Shields the existing Barn
from the childcare and Wells worn roads
the removal will expose the existing
building fully to these two Vantage
problems and will have a negative impact
on the traditional setting
the application before you proposes two
dwellings that are smaller than the
existing agricultural Barn they have
less total fill space and volume
compared with the extent class Q
permission and have a more sympathetic
language that will enhance the setting
of the former Farmstead whilst also
providing a benefit in terms of impact
on the wider Countryside
the planning officer has accepted in
their assessment that the fallback
position represents a material
consideration
as such ultimately decision before you
this evening is quite simple
which one would you prefer
thank you
well within your time I like to see
um
any questions catch the party please
thank you Chan good evening
can you advise whether the conifers that
are to be removed for this particular
application of are they would they also
be removed for the class queue
so that is a condition on the permission
so they have to come out so the conifers
are being removed so it would expose
either of the properties correct yeah
thank you
catch the foreman please
thank you good evening could I just
clarify did you say there were seven
dwellings already on the side or there
will be seven with these two
there are seven there currently as
approved and these would add a further
two to the site
all right thank you I can't see any
other questions so Mr good all you all
free to go thank you very much thank you
and our next speaker will be
counselor Richards the ward member
all right then councilor Richards you've
got five minutes once I've worked out
the technology and once you're ready as
well
so far away
thank you Jim members you'll note from
the case officer report that the
fallback position has been established
and accepted uh that being the class
queue approval for three two bedroom
dwellings ultimately your decision today
hinges on whether you consider the
proposal to be more or less harmful than
the approved class queue if it's more
harmful refuse if it's less harmful
Grant in my opinion it is less harmful
the reason for the refusals as set out
in the officers report suggests that the
proposal would be a significant
departure from the existing site layout
Now The Wider site is made up of
converted brick buildings of similar
design and style to that of the proposed
whereas the class Q permission would
retain a green corrugated metal clad
flat roof barn that in no way resembles
or complements the existing site layout
the second reason for refusal suggest an
over development of the site with poor
amenity areas and parking spaces whilst
I do not disagree that the proposed
dwellings would result in a larger floor
area than that of the class queue I do
not consider the proposal to be an
overdevelopment of the site The Wider
development site has a vast amount of
space and the proposed would sit
comfortably within that space whilst
also complementing the already already
sensitively converted Farmhouse and
buildings
similarly when considering the immunity
space available under the class Q
permission each of the three dwellings
would benefit from between 33 and 35
square meters of cartilage most of which
is taking that by parking leaving little
to a no amenity space available for the
occupiers of each dwelling
under the proposed the properties would
benefit from between 50 square meters
and 58 square meters of unity space plus
parking provision for two cars I failed
to see how that isn't seen as a
betterment an improvement and therefore
less harmful than the accepted fallback
case officer asserts that the proposal
would be a prominent feature within the
landscape particularly when considering
relationship with the wider former
agricultural farmstead I don't disagree
however the same could be said for the
green corrugated metal clad flat roof
barn that as I said earlier in no way
resembles that all complements the
existing site frankly it's a bit of an
eyesore
I would suggest that the existing and
approved class queue would detract from
the existing site layout more so than to
the two dwellings that have been
proposed here that will complement the
sensitively converted farm and buildings
that make up the wider site so for those
reasons I consider the proposal to be
less harmful than the class q and
request that you grant planning
permission thank you very much
thank you councilor riches again well
within time which is what we'd like to
see um any questions for the ward member
please
cancer Curtis please
thank you councilor Richards um just a
point of clarification if you could on
the garden
plot sizes and because in in the officer
report on page 14 says the um
first paragraph
plot Nine's usable Garden area is to be
approximately 34 meter meters square
meters
which is below the required 50 square
meters but you you'll you seem to give
some slightly different interpretation
could you just run over that again for
us please of course I can so you can see
on the site plan above you the Garden
area that is proposed I think it's plot
the I can't actually read from here it's
too small is it plot plot nine so plot
nine I believe is 50 square meters and
plot eight I believe is 58 square meters
it's entirely up to the occupier how
they use their land it is all usable
because it's all Garden space so it's up
to you how you use it that is an
interpretation by the case officer which
is perfectly acceptable
um I would say that it is all usable
thank you
that's a party please
thank you chair uh councilor Richards uh
I wonder whether you can clarify or
advise if you have received any
objections from the nearby residents to
this new application in terms of its
design and also obviously aware that
child cook Parish Council
um haven't made any representations
um just be interested to know what sort
of consultation might have taken place
um and what sort of feedback you might
have had I noticed there are no
objections in writing from the parish
um over to you
I've heard of no objections from any of
the local residents or indeed as you say
the parish council and there is only one
objection listed on the file and I
believe that's from cpre it's worth
noting that the other seven dwellings
that obviously are not part of this site
they are part of a previous application
were objected to by The National Trust
who neighbor it the National Trust have
not objected on this occasion so I think
you can take from that what you will
all right I'll count any further
questions
you are free to go thank you very much
come back to the chair free quickly
we will now move on to points for
clarification
any questions came to the Harvey please
um page 14 paragraph three uses the term
the contrived design
could an explanation could the office
give an explanation of whether that's a
technical description if it's not a
technical description what led her to
use those words
um so in my view when assessing this I
can say the design is contrived in so
far as because of the layout
um and in so far that it's over
development of the site and how the
arrangement of the plots are on the size
of the site which
um as a result because of the layout in
how it is we in my view at their
immunity space isn't
um
particularly usable and also because of
this base that also results in the
parking spaces which do not Accord to
the size and space standards so it's a
combination of factors which have led me
to use that wording as a contrived
layout and Design
here's the roofing cancel apparently
oh thank you
um so is there any way you can show me
um the access
where the parking spaces are and if any
are there any visitor parking spaces on
this site please
so the parking spaces are um so for plot
nine here
um and plot eight are here
the access for this site is so this is
the existing building so it's on the
national cycle route there are no
visitor parking spaces for this proposal
but because of the number of units
against the development requirements SPD
guidance there wouldn't be a requirement
to provide visitor parking spaces may I
just follow up so in terms of parking
um I believe that
in the highways opinion there isn't
adequate
parking for each the highways haven't
objected on parking grounds in terms of
my concern with parking is that this
spaces that have been provided don't
meet with the size standard okay okay
but the number of spaces that have been
provided is sufficient for the size of
the dwellings that are proposed okay so
I'm just gonna go back to visitor
parking
is there an area on that site where
visitors can park
and having been involved with the wider
site I am mindful that there is visitor
parking provided for The Wider Courtyard
area but obviously this is a separate
application
um so that would be outside of the
application area
three from the price of one there
councilor off I'm very impressed no no
it's fine that was good good not a
problem with a cancer party please then
councilor Harvey again that's all right
I just wondered whether I could have
some clarification on the update sheet
um where we
um make reference to the existing
agricultural bonds volume is 638 cubic
meters and then it says by comparison
the proposed volume of the two dwellings
is six 22 square meters
should be cubic apologies that's all
right
just want to prove I've read the update
sheet well I'm in frescoes the Paris I
hadn't picked that up so very very good
you get to get the the chocolate for
spotting that Carissa Harvey please uh
thank you chairman
um the uh class Q application seems to
be relevant here as a point of
comparison is it possible to provide a
slide which shows the layout proposed
under the class Q permission
please
um I've only got the um ground floor um
to hand right now and let me see if I
can zoom in
so um they were two so they were two
bedrooms and bathroom upstairs and then
this is the ground floor layout um which
shows um a living in kitchen area with
downstairs mwc
sorry cancel Harvey are you happy or
you've got a supplementary on that one
here's what it is thank you I think I
know what councilor Perry is going to
say I just wanted to know some
clarification on the parking for the
class queue says in comparison to what
the application is in front of us so
obviously with class Q
um regulations the parking would be
within the um the area the curtainage
area so there the parking would have to
be within um the the colored areas which
are shown on that plan
I think if I can just add to that I
think um something to clarify is that
the class queue granted three dwellings
of two bedrooms each so the number of
bedrooms between the two schemes is the
same but like Amy said we were satisfied
in assessing the class queue that the
level of parking was acceptable in terms
of being able to be provided within the
cartilage of those those units
any other questions or points of
clarification before we go into the
debate cats for me just sneaked in there
sorry can I do on the class queue that
the three two bedrooms have they got any
Garden space I can't tell from that
place
um so the um
the the color the colored areas for each
unit would be
um potentially the Garden area which
would be for so the immunity areas that
would be parking garden and because of
the regulations of class Q
um the the
um sort of immediate area around the
building can't be any larger than the
size of the footprint of the building so
because of their nature they do have
small amenity areas
all right well then move on to the
debate who wants to kick off cancer
Dixon thank you very much
thank you chairman
always a bit of an issue when you're
looking at the fallback situation with
uh with glass q and what have you
um but certainly looking at the image we
had previously of the overall complex
uh I don't see any agricultural activity
going on I see a situation whereby a
traditional Old Farm has been mostly
converted into residential
and we have if you like a a green thumb
of a corrugated shed left behind
it's got classical permission full
conversion but it's not an attractive
site to my mind if those Evergreens come
down it will indeed be very visible I
appreciate that the Evergreens will come
down irrespective of what goes on on
this site but essentially I am minded to
go against the officer recommendation
and propose that this is actually
granted I think the amenity spaces
available to two properties
the
cubic volume of the two is the same as
the barn and I think ultimately it will
look more like a converted
Farm yard complex inter-residential of
the whole and not through properties and
a nice oil left over
thank you foreign
reasons for me please so uh so we can do
this okay it's probably a priest then
cancel it
thank you chair
um
I think this is a
this is not an unusual application in
recent months we seem to be having a
number of
um new designs coming forward in sort of
a class queue
um approved application
um but I'm minded to support this
application we've had no and I think
this is really important there are no
local objections at all no objections
from child-cut Parish Council
no local objections and I note on the
update sheet we have two letters of
support
in my view It's Not Unusual to receive
an objection from the cpre
um as that that tends to happen with
this type of
um application
I'm really quite familiar with the site
having lived in the area before
um
39 years and I do remember the old
Farmstead at kingsmead very attractive
building and I think the new conversions
and how they have created a courtyard
development is is very appealing
um I think the the fallback situation
would just be a block on the landscape
with the corrugated roofs and it would
I also think the kingsmead development
is actually in a very prominent space
particularly is it's the Gateway into
childcut which is bordered by The
National Trust we don't have any
objection from The National Trust
and I have absolutely no reason why we
shouldn't approve and I would like to
Second councilor Dixon's proposal thank
you cancer power it must have been very
young 39 years ago of course certainly
if you could keep an eye on again those
reasons as well for going against office
recommendation at Council Mills please
thank you so much cancer barriers um
stolen most of my thunder all I'm not
going to say is any Improvement on this
site
um third the
recommendation by Council Dixon thank
you
Harvey please I can see you yeah thank
you chairman
um
having heard the officers report I I was
persuaded that there was a good grounds
for refusal I understand why the
officers
come to her view
having listened to the presentation and
the discussion
um I'm sat here thinking if this had
been an application for a single
dwelling almost anything that was
reasonable it we wouldn't be sad here
that would have been approved so my
dilemma is
um
the question of of is this over
development and there are arguments that
the immunity space is inadequate and
doesn't meet requirements
on the other hand I'm persuaded I think
by councilor Richard's view of what the
classical alternative would look like
and on balance
I think I'm I'm I'm prepared to go along
with the proposal that we Grant rather
than refuse
yeah
any other points of the debate
I'll I'll throw my two penny with within
whilst I'm here
um yeah I think I agree with uh
councilor Harvey but that it's not over
development to the side
um complement existing buildings
oh sorry and um
Improvement on the visual impact and the
impact on locally as well so they were
my three points um
catch the dicks on any happy for like to
delay complement your your reasons they
do I think basically I think we all seem
to be in agreement uh Jim and that the
the alternative design that is presented
to us this evening instead of the class
queue is more acceptable than the class
Q fall back position and therefore we
should give that greater weight than the
full Bank
Alice has got some points of
clarification here
uh thank you chairman so just for
clarity I just wanted to come back to
you to clarify the reasons to make sure
that I've understood matters correctly
if the vote does proceed and succeed
um so members um or the proposal is
minded that the alternative design
proposed here is more acceptable than
the class queue
um as a result of traditional farm
buildings converted on The Wider site
it's more in keeping the class queue is
not attractive very visible
um and the immunity space is acceptable
and will look more like a converted Farm
building as opposed to the I saw that is
the class queue does that kind of pick
up and uh also I've got a comment that
there wasn't an over development of the
site provided by councilor cramp are you
happy that that kind of encompasses the
reasons why your minded to go against
the recommendation perfect Alice
excellent thank you
cancel how are you happy with those as
well yes I am I just wanted to emphasize
I feel there is less harm from a
planning perspective than the class
queue
um
permission
I was ably reminded by a little voice on
my right hand side about conditions
um I'll be a list of standard list of
conditions and other members any
conditions they want to apply to this
one as well removal of permitted
development rights
yeah
okay so I've come prepared and I have a
list
um
so um time plans and land contamination
and land um remediation conditions
they've been um requested by
environmental health and we would need
to seek agreement to those from the
applicant because they would be
pre-commencement and material schedule
and the access and visibility conditions
which have been requested by highways
hard and soft Landscaping the
recommendations of the bat survey remove
permitted development rights and part
one class a to e and part two class A
and climate climate change checklist
bins water butts and the sill phasing
condition
as well as a couple of notes I can State
those if you want me to or
right I think we've that's really
comprehensive
um should we go to the vote on this
please all those in favor of
agreeing to Grant this application
brilliant thank you committee resolves
to Grant application 22
03276 f u l now we'll pass over to the
capable hands of councilor riches thank
you
foreign
apologies to all of our officers I
enthusiastically charged into the agenda
without introducing you all so I'm I'm
sorry for that
right let's dive into our next item of
the evening which is application
reference
2203636 ful and
2203637 LBC our presenting officer is
Marvin
over to you
thank you chairman good evening everyone
um so I'm presenting tonight to an
application
um at Meadow Cottage in avondasset and
this is a full application and a listed
building constant
so
um Meadow Cottage is a great to list it
property within a row of three attached
Cottages as you can see
um on this plan
the application property is in the
middle and
um to the Southwest is post box
um Cottage and to the north east is a
victory Cottage
and the property dates back to the
middle of the 18th century and is
situated within a conservation area as
well as ironso Iron Stone Hill special
landscape area
there is also a public food path that
runs
um to the south west of the three
Cottages which leads to even Cairo
to the to the South
[Music]
um
on the second slide you can see the
application site in The Wider area
oh sorry
oh sorry I can go back again to show the
location one okay
um so in terms of what is being proposed
is
um
planning permission is sold for two and
single story extensions to the rear of
the cottage as well as a change of views
of land to residential
um
in the rear to facilitate a new
vehicular access and drive
um
and on this slide you can see on the
left hand side the existing site plan
here you can see the main Cottage and
this is a single story
rear Conservatory
and on the right hand side you can see
the proposed two-story extension there
and single story extensions
there
which wraps around
um the two the proposed two-story
extension as well as the neighboring
property
um and here is would be the the new axis
and the next slide you can see on the
left hand side
existing plants and elevations and on
the right hand side proposed so here is
the existing ground floor plan this this
is proposed this is existing first floor
plan and this is proposed with a
two-story extension there and you can
see the roof plan of the single story
extension
here you can see the
existing rear elevation of the main
Cottage
where this is the single story
conservatory and this is the original
rear wall
on the proposed elevations you can see
the single story extensions there and
this would be a two-story extension
including side elevation
on this slide you can see
the proposed section and elevation of
the vehicular axis
and the proposed to Gates
uh
there you on the on the left hand side
at the bottom you can see our photo of
the access way so this is looking
um
towards the main village road from the
access way alongside the side boundary
of the Cottages so the Cottages are
located here
and
there runs the main village road this is
the access way and just behind the shed
would be located the new axis
the other photo on the right hand side
shows
The View towards the the bottom of the
sides where the axis would be
just over there
this is the front of the property the
application property is located in the
middle this is
post box Cottage and this is Victory
Cottage
and this is the rear elevation
this is a part of the neighboring
dwelling
and you can see the scale of the
existing extension as well
um chairman the recommendation is to
refuse both applications on the grounds
of Heritage Farm
which was considered in
the Heritage arm
um
was considered less than substantial
and also public benefits were considered
and they do not outweigh the harm that
would arise as a result of this
development
thank you
Albina thank you very much indeed um
let's call our first speaker on this
item who is counselor Phil Baxter of
Avon dassett Parish Council
good evening councilor Baxter and thank
you for your patience okay so when
you're sat comfortable and ready to go
you'll have three minutes I'll give you
a 30 second warning before your time is
up
and if you press the button on the right
it will turn red and the floor is yours
thank you much chair and good evening
councilors
um so I'm speaking on behalf as a
counselor on behalf of Evan dashik um
Parish Council to confirm that we had no
objection when this application was
discussed in our polish council meeting
so firstly on the extension
Meadow Cottage is the middle of a row of
three Cottages in the village all of
which are listed buildings but all which
have been significantly altered in the
past
the slideshow is one of two substantial
fires that took place in the last
century one was in 1904 and then this
one in March 1935. as councilors can see
the exterior and the interior of meadow
Cottage shown in the newspaper cutting
was substantially substantially
destroyed leading to the extent sorry
leading to extensive internal and
external rebuilding all three Cottages
have existing rear extensions that were
erected in the period since the fire the
council therefore considered the
demolition of the existing extension and
the replacement by another as not
causing significant harm to the listed
building and commensurate with the
extensions of the listed cottages on
either side
secondly we considered the change of
views from the garden to a rear driveway
Evan dassic Parish plan was adopted in
2022 and found that on-street parking
one of the chief concerns of the local
residents as such the provision of
parking behind the cottage is welcome as
is the installation of an electric
vehicle charging point this is
preferable to having such provision at
the front of the property on the highway
although this would necessitate the
removal of a domestic Garden the
benefits were seen to outweigh the loss
of the immunity
the Polish council did have some
concerns about the access to the
driveway which is via a privately owned
Road
in summary the parish council saw no
reason to object to the extension and
rear driveway and return the decision of
no objection
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
cancer Parry first please
thank you and good evening
um can you advise was there was there a
split photo Tool uh the parish council
regarding no objection
and is and
if I can have the answer to that one
first
yeah we had one Declaration of interest
but the rest of us were unanimous so
unanimous for no objection but you had
no wishes to support it
yeah um where we do understand some of
the points raised over the listed
building and we saw the benefits our
word this so we when we have no
objection
okay any other questions for our
counselor please Council Harvey now this
is perhaps going a bit too far
um I notice in that photograph
that the roof material is thatched in
the in the current photography it is a
tiled roof do you know anything about
what sort of roof there was prior to the
first fire in 190
two or five
um no I couldn't answer that sorry
counselor thank you
okay any other questions members
no council Baxter thank you very much
your time contribution this evening
thank you very much
okay let's call our next speakers who
are our agents Mr Greg dick and our
applicant Mr Simon Sergio
I hope I pronounced that correctly
first ah result
okay gentlemen are you going to be
splitting your time so you've got three
minutes between the
um just yourself okay um in that case
whenever
button on the right it'll turn red okay
the floor is now yours the conservation
officer reports centers on the
property's grade 2 listing within the
group setting of that includes the
neighbors properties as a Heritage asset
this listing briefly mentions The Gables
of meadow Cottage but the conservation
officer appears to pay this
disproportionate value on the twin
Gables and the wall despite the Heritage
statement citing the incorrect historic
location maps the properties location is
not disputed and should not undermine
the written content which questions the
age and value of the historic building
the fire of 1935 completely destroyed
the property but the listing describes
Meadow Cottage as a mid-18th century
which we have proved was entirely
rebuilt after 1935. it's responsible to
assume so it's reasonable to assume that
the gables didn't exist and were added
as part of the 20th century rebuild
therefore no historic elements of the
original property or rear elevation are
left to consider modern materials such
as rsjs chimney stack and roof beams
support this fact arguably this confirms
the listing was done on the strength of
their Collective set setting within the
streetscape not individual Merit
we feel the extension subservient
composition and design fits comfortably
within the irregular formation of both
neighbors substantial two-story
extensions which were both completed
after the 1987 listing
our proposed first floor sits well
within the rear building line of both
neighbors larger extensions while the
ground floor area extends to infill the
established rear building line
the case officer states that the
neighbors Cottages have different
features but the only two words Heritage
England refers to regarding rear
features are irregular fenestration
the officer reports states that the
proposal being wholly unacceptable and
unsympathetic when last year's report
described the exact same proposal as a
Creative Design with a variation of a
historic theme This truly highlights the
subjective nature of the process
we question the conservation officer's
observation that the proposed windows
and doors are dominating in random
contrasting with the symmetry of the
cottage the first floor is clearly
symmetrical the lightweight composition
preserves and extends the exact the
existing Gables profile giving a
sensitive interpretation while the
ground floor matches Horton Stone and
Oak which are well established natural
materials used within the village this
will enable the property's evolution to
be clearly read while preserving the
existing Gable internally 30 seconds we
respectfully ask the members to take a
balanced View and assess this in the
contexts of the listed group setting
within the established presidents of the
neighbor's extensions we've submitted 15
long-term public benefits that are
social economic and environmental which
we believe outweigh what little history
is left after the rebuild the house was
only 47 years old when listed however
our plan creates a modest sized family
home sympathetically reflecting locality
and the character of the house without
compromise in the cons of area
Conservation Area it sits on thank you
perfect timing thank you very much
members do we have any questions what
applicant or agent councilor Parry
please
thank you chair and good evening
I note in the planning officers report
the it makes reference to six letters of
objection can you advise do you know
whether your immediate neighbors object
to your plans at all uh yes so my
neighbor on the well as you're looking
at the back of the building the neighbor
on the right is that's Rosary Cottage I
think so I think malwina may have said
Victory Cottage but Victory Cottage used
to be Meadow Cottage then they changed
the name to you know from Victory to
Meadow Rosary Cottage has no objections
the neighbor to the left of us which was
it's gonna get confusing sorry
Ravenscroft but now it's called post box
Cottage it's not the old post office
um they've got no objections to the
plans itself and initially welcomed the
idea of you know a
like an extension next to this to butt
up so it would insulate their home and
you know it was quite quite well
received but then they have put some
objections in to do with they think they
own
of course you know I would disagree but
they think they're in like five or ten
centimeters of land
past their kitchen wall so that's what
they were objecting to today well you
can't build there because that's my land
and I think the the officers said well
that's not a planning issue that's a
like a legal issue of where you can
build up to so that's what they were
objecting to in regards to the actual
build itself
okay any other questions members Council
Harvey
just to pursue that am I right in
thinking of of all of the letters of
objection none has been to the extension
per se but the objections have been to
the Rogue access at the back that's
that's my understanding is that your
understanding yes correct so we had uh I
think three or four letters of of
objection from Avon Cairo just regarding
the road they had some concerns about
um drainage and such like which have
been dealt with by my architect and I
think the case officers maybe spoken to
them but they did not object to the
build itself it was just the access
cancer Curtis thank you thank you
um I just want to I you mentioned a
different response I believe it was from
the conservation officer
from and could you just clarify again
you was it exactly the same application
if you could just clarify that point
please yes I mean okay you can talk if
you want but I can also say we we put in
the exact same application it was
exactly the same application which was
withdrawn
and could you just clarify again the the
previous conservation officers comments
it's a case officer all the case I'm
sorry I couldn't quite get
um as well
you yeah the Creative Design it was the
conservation officers
um within his consultation
um he referred to as a Creative Design
with variation and historic theme
um and that didn't raise any objections
previously that came from the
conservation officer
at the time Mr Seger could you if you're
going to speak if you wouldn't mind
putting yeah
sorry I'm gonna be a slight pain here
the the reason it's flashing green is
because Mr Dix is still on you were
queued there we go yeah I think I just
said the officer's report but it was the
conservation officer who said in the
last one which we put in I think we put
it in like April and it went through
around August he said the Creative
Design with the historic you know
variation on the theme it's the same
case officer who's commented on this
application which is we haven't changed
it one bit
thanks for that
Council Ralph
uh if I'm allowed to ask this question
can you tell me why you withdrew the
previous application if the conservation
officer was in favor
um the cake well I'll speak first but
they keep they weren't in favor of it
but they they said the theming and the
the build was you know the application
itself and the design was good but they
had an issue with the the wall and the
Gable but Greg can explain a bit further
than I can
that possible to explain
it comes with an old subjectivity of the
of the process
[Music]
um
may I just clarify something have you
put in exactly the same application you
haven't changed anything at all
the the only change was to the boundary
treatment of the access drive that was
the only difference
I think to help members we might just
write this one down and get it clarified
by officers at the appropriate time I
always seems to be going around in
circles we're going to move on from that
does anyone else have any questions for
either our applicant or our agent
no in that case Mr segu Mr Dick thank
you very much for time contribution this
evening
we will call our final speaker on this
item is cancer Fielding
okay cancel the Fielding you'll have
five minutes whenever your sat comes
from ready to go if you press the button
on the right uh the actor the microphone
will be active and the floor is yours
the other right
thank you
um this is the first time I've seen a
planning officer correct a in a
committee report award members
support for a scheme my comments were
General
comments referring to rulings that had
been given by various judges on the
subject
there are two parts to this application
the full and the LBC
on page 29
of the office's report
the officer clearly states that there is
no problem
with the application citing various
parts of the course strategy
the officer considers on balance the
extension displayed sufficient level of
subservience to the host building to
satisfy the elements tree requirements
of the district council policy 20.
further furthermore cs20 in paragraph F
requires requirements state that the
proposals will preserve and enhance the
character of the locality
in light of the above I consider the
principles development would be in
accordance with cs-12 920 and as10
subject to the proposed extension being
um
applicable to the character of the house
building and its setting as the
applicant works from home full-time
cs22 is relevant
LBC the LBC and cs8 deal with securing
the viable use of a Heritage asset
supporting support of a long-term
conservation
I've asked us to show that slide so
you'll
note from the slide you'll see that the
two Cottages are on either side of
meadow Cottage were destroyed Rosemary
Cottage on the right of the image was
extended under an application into 2006.
post office Cottage was expect extended
in 1999. could you show the second of my
two slides please
I'm being told we only have one cancer
feeling sorry I'm being told we only
have one I gave sent two in
one
um
Allison was was unhappy with but there
was definitely the other one
showing the extensions of the two other
properties either side of this one
bear with us and we will find what we
have
I have paused your time I don't know
whether Howard's got them because I sent
them to him
over this Castle film
I hope the clock stopped
30 seconds
questions
you'll be pleased to know we're here to
have found that hazar so we will just
bring it up there with
I have it here if anybody wants to see
it
I said John with we have found it we're
just bringing it out okay thank you
thank you okay John as soon as you start
speaking I'll start the clock again okay
pushbox on which is fine which finalized
in 1999.
the cottage on the Green in warmington
approved by yourselves based on public
benefits of bringing the property and
accommodation up to the 21st century
standards
the conservation is cons ENT about the
back wall and the rare Gables of the
property following the fire in 1935 the
property including this wall was
completely rebuilt with modern materials
I and probably some of the old materials
I can therefore cannot see any
historical significance of this wall
apart from the fact local Stone was used
and still used
so what are the public benefits under
cs8 the committee should consider the
viability of preserving the property by
bringing accommodation up to the 21st
century this will allow a young couple
who to have sufficient room to start a
family and adequate space for home
working cs22
it is in my view a social benefit as per
uh ppf paragraph eight with pattern the
nppf is vague on public benefits and
therefore various judgments
have been have given their repent judges
have given their opinion on public
benefits the role of the conservation
officer is a technical consultee
inspectors have allowed this type of
development where it is improves the
accommodation it is up to the planning
officer knowing all the facts
to give an opinion on the application
first part I've set out on page 29 30
seconds I believe that the officer's
option
opinion that this should be a grant the
conservation office only a consultee and
it is left to the planning officer and
the committee to decide and I would like
to see this matter granted
John thank you very much indeed members
do we have any questions for councilor
Fielding please
no in that case Council sir Fielding
thank you very much for your time
contribution this evening
and now we'll move into points of
clarification with our officers we of
course have I've got you that Council
Rolf but we will of course go to the
discussion we were having earlier on
about the previous application that was
withdrawn what has materially changed
and I think there's some confusion over
comments made by the uh conservation
officer Alice if you wouldn't mind
giving us a Lowdown on that please yeah
of course thank you chairman um so just
to clarify this application follows the
withdrawal of an earlier submission
which related to the same scheme I've
got the conservation officers comments
in front of me relating to the withdrawn
application and he does indeed say that
the proposed extension is a Creative
Design with a variation of a historic
theme he does however go on to say
however whilst following the modeling of
the existing rear it would more than
double the depth the window layout is
dominating and contrasts with the
solidarity of the vernacular Stone
ranges the lead infill to the roof
valley and the area of the flat roof
element which tracks from and compete
with the more modern character of the
rear the historical would be masked
completely and its contribution to the
building's overall interest would be
removed the proposal would significantly
compromise the historic composition and
scale and it does go on to say a couple
of other things but I think the point to
make is that yes he did say that snippet
in his consultation response but he
obviously then went on to identify that
harm which is consistent with the harm
that we've identified with this
application
Alice that's great thank you very much
indeed councilor Rolfe please uh yes I
have two very brief points and first one
is about this picture so when I when the
extension comes out the window on the
right hand side of the right of the
cottage on the right hand side not that
window the one
the inner one
will that be affected likewise from the
extension that comes forward from the
middle Cottage
is there any 45 degree rule that's
um you know
so
um
it is noted that the 45 degree rule
would be bridged but uh the proposed
two-story extension would not uh
would not be taller than a day existing
first floor window at this Cottage and
the 25 would not be breached by by this
extension so overall it has been
assessed that there would be no harmful
impacts on the neighboring amenity thank
you um and my second point is um in one
of the um points of objection it talks
about a steep drop of the driveway can
you show me that driveway again the
access and and whether and and are you
able to do are you able to demonstrate
how steep that is
it's difficult to see how steep it is I
it
uh is that a sort of one in six or a one
in four or a how steep is it
I would quickly check um measure on the
bun
well while maravino's checking do we
have any other questions councilor
Harvey first please
um
this property was listed in 1987.
as an 18 as one of a Terrace of three
18th century cottages
was a conservation officer aware of the
fire in 1935 and the consequences
um yes and we received this information
about the fire damage and basically just
to clarify that the properties were
listed after the fires and the listing
entry actually takes into account that
the Cottages were significantly rebuilt
and re-rooved nevertheless the
properties were still considered
of a high interest and hence they were
listed and
um
the information about the fire and the
photograph showing the fire damage was
sent to the conservation officer and he
replied with the following if if I may
quote
um
the background is interesting but this
doesn't change the assessment as set out
in my report and the rear wall may be
the original or may have been rebuilt in
part or whole if structurally unsound
and the actual full circumstances aren't
evident
what is clear that the wall remains in
the historic position and the stonework
is likely to be original unless it can
be proven otherwise
the new extension would completely hide
the rear and be a
in terms of massing articulation and
materials this will radically change the
sense of scale and originality of the
building's vernacular as a whole and it
is also worth noting that the listing
entry on the historic England's website
specifically refers to the twin Gables
in the rear as well
thank you
cancer Parry please thank you chair
um Can the officers advise if the rear
of the properties can be seen by a
public footpath
because
um to me obviously the the
front of the properties are very
attractive
and set the character of The Cottages
where we now have the rear of the
Cottages where we have these two
extensions I'm just very interested to
know whether the rear of the properties
can be seen from any public viewpoint
um so I wouldn't say that
um the rear of the property can be
seen it's not exposed to any prominent
views
um although it is noteworthy that there
is a public footpath and in the future
it might be more exposed
um but
um the conservation officer also
clarified this point as well and he
stated in his comments that
um
listed listed buildings
um they have they carry a lot of
interest for example the interior
but which is not visible to the public
right but it is still worthy preserving
um so I just wanted to raise that point
thank you
before I call them cancer Mills have we
got a rough idea of how Steve landslope
is
this this plan this plan shows I think
really as much as we can advise so the
level difference is shown here
um so I think we it's a slightly less
blurry plan so you can see from the
level of the initial part of the kind of
access over here
it's 2.45
up to the kind of tallest section so I
don't want to quote what the warning
because I don't want to get it wrong so
so may I just then come back to it
because it says here I mean presumably
you you had a site visit and it says
here that
um
it's called problems and problems of
safety uh for traffic and pedestrians
going from Avon Caro
so is that the case did you see that
in terms of the steepness of the of the
access
it's difficult and so I as you can see
here there is
um like a retaining wall and obviously
um the gradient would be
it it would be quite as steep
um
rump in a way
but the county highways were satisfied
that the proposals would not result in
any harm to highway safety and and on
that and also
um the county rights of way team also
were consulted and they also had no
objection so on that basis
um we concluded that there would be no
harm to highway safety or pedestrian
safety
Council Mills please
thank you Mr chairman umina could you
put the photograph up of the rear
of the proposed development please can
you put that up
showing the conservatory
that's it right just to get in my my
mind that
that consumption is going yeah
right that's going uh
the the two The Gables is that coming
out as well
that's coming further out by four is it
four meters
yes so looking at the proposed floor
plans uh the extension would
um extend directly from the existing
twin Gables so that would be the
two-story extension and then there will
be also
um a single story extension that wraps
around yeah
this building here and that was sorry
and that would only go out as far as the
or further than that existing building
on the right
so um on this slide
this would be the accident of the
two-story extension so it would not
project Beyond
extension of the neighboring property
that's lovely thank you very much
that's a hobby
we know in this property was listed 1987
do we have any date for when the
conservation area was created please
not off the top of my head and I
wouldn't want to Hazard a guess without
further research
I think the point to make is the
property was listed in 1987 post the
fire and it's a listed building
I think the the question of the date of
the conservation area is relevant
because it's the second part of the test
under the planning listed buildings and
conservation areas act 1990 and I I the
reason I want to know it if it's if it's
knowable is because I want to know that
that date in relation to the consents
which have already been given for for
extensions on the neighboring two
properties which I want to know whether
they were also in the conservation area
at the time they were given their
permissions that's why I want to know
we will try and find out
I would just as I have done in many
times in the past remind members that we
are here to consider the application in
front of us not applications on other
sites that have happened in the past
I appreciate your thought process I need
to make that point
the conservation area review even does
it was undertaken in January 1999.
okay councilor Harvey have you got
another question
nope has anyone else got any points of
clarification before we move into the
debate
let's move to the base who likes kick us
off
Council Dixon please
uh if I go back a number of years
um that conservation was a conservation
review
and I suspect the conservation area was
probably struck because my memory tells
me that way back in the 90s practically
every village in the Stratford area
District when he uh age already had a
Conservation Area
Etc certainly Tamworth did
Etc
um looking at that uh I can see Merit in
the application
the two properties I needed properties
on either side have had their extensions
done the original walls if they ever
were original after the fire have
obviously been lost in those two
instances and I see no great harm in
losing the the middle section and
essentially uh I would be supportive of
this application I'll uh I'll wait to
see what other comments are before
possibly proposing a grant to Jim
thank you Council Dixon Council Mills
yeah thanks for chairman yeah I'm
looking at this and you know I quite
agree with councilor Dixon there
so I can't see the harm in this at the
moment Mr chairman uh it's not produced
protruding any further than the either
side of the extensions either side
um I wait to hear what other people are
saying but I've at the moment minded to
uh go for Grant on this Mr chairman
thank you
thank you very much Council Harvey
please
thank you
um
I'm very much on the line of council
Dixon and I'm on that line because
um
these three properties were are a single
listing
they have to be considered in their
entirety together as a as three
terrorists
the
both cottages on either side have been
amended extended one in my my date is
1992 not 1999 and 2006. and the people
who made those decisions were under the
same obligation under the 1990 act in
relation to uh certainly a special
regard and possibly also special
attention
and they made their decisions
while I take the point that the
conservation officer that
um the interior of a property can be
just as interesting as the exterior I
don't think he points to anything on the
inside that is of particular historic
Merit the properties we rebuilt in 1990
1935 or thereabouts with modern
materials
the properties can be viewed as they are
from the from the street scene and their
historic such as it is integrity can be
appreciated from from the front there
have been no objections from local
residents about the design there is no
objection from the parish council while
two wrongs or in this case two wrongs
don't necessarily make a right
um that's probably the not not not a
really apt quotation but
um
I don't see an overwhelming reason why
the opinion the view of a conservation
officer and I can quote personal
experience where conservation officers
opinions have been overturned by
planning inspectors
um
it is it is our responsibility
decision-making body not the
conservation officers and on balance I'm
inclined to support this application
cancer off
um I think I think I'm in general
agreement with covered so far I think
also the fact that these uh the backs of
these cartridges are not seen
and already there's been two extensions
at either side I find it really
difficult to to
um put any objection really to an
extension in the middle
um I I think if if we did I think you
know it would immediately be refuted at
appeal
um I don't have as as councilor Perry
said that there have been no objections
by the neighbors I think
on the whole on balance
um I think I approve of this application
cancer Kendall please
thank you chairman
um look these uh listed building
applications are always tricky for me uh
I like to see them come to committee
because what it measures is what I think
of is like the head versus heart
decision and I think on this application
it's a perfect example I think Marina
you've done a fantastic job on this one
I think you represent the head and
you've you know you've given the buy the
book response the report is excellent
but I think I'm going to be led by my
heart because I'm not seeing the harm
and I think most of everybody else has
said the same thing
you look at this we know we're trying to
preserve the character of a listed
building make sure it's not harmed in
any way but you can sometimes improve
the listed building for the occupiers at
the moment and for future Generations
which is what we're looking at here I
can't like to quote out something else I
cannot find any harm really yes it's
changing a listed building but change is
not necessarily the same as harm so I'm
happy to go along with this and I will
propose that we Grant uh both both
applications the full analysted building
thank you very much Council kennel
Council Curtis next please I don't need
to write anything else German
you don't want to Second it
yep very happy to say she's usually
quite helpful otherwise I can't proceed
so just so I'm clear you're seconding
the proposal to Grant the full and your
second in The Proposal was Grant the LBC
thank you very much cancer Parry
thank you chair I was going to Second
um but counselor Curtis speak me to it
via your good self
um and I think I would just confirm the
fact that when the officer said the the
rear of the property could not be seen
from a public it just totally swayed
swayed me and um I'm very much in
support of this application due to I
cannot identify any harm let alone less
than significant harm
okay I don't think anyone has got their
hand up or have put their hands up I'm
just going to Chuck in uh some thoughts
from me um Council Harvey made some very
valid points um about the conservation
Act of 1990
um and that the extensions in 1992 and
2006 happened on the neighboring
properties I would point out that it's
worth bearing in mind that at that time
there were very different both local and
National planning uh policies uh we are
in a very different environment now
um just something to bear in mind when
you're making your decision
um and uh for me
um the bulk at the back of the property
I think if indeed as we've been told the
listing is for the grouping of the
properties does materially change the
layout and setup of that
so something else to bear in mind when
you're making your decision I accept
that there is a as Council Kendall put a
head versus heart
I'm Bound by the policies and I must
operate with my head unfortunately
I'm sorry to Mr Sergio I'm not going to
be voting in favor for those reasons and
I believe it will go against our
policies and there's no point in having
policies if we're going to go against
them
but there we are
um I believe uh we have very briefly
proceed the reasons we're going against
the officer's recommendation so Alice if
I could ask you to run through those
please
absolutely thank you chairman
um so the reasons I have is that um
councilor Kendall I think proposed
um that there's no harm to the list of
building
um because it's listed as part of the
three Cottages it should be read as a
single entity with the other two
Cottages which have already been
extended and the bulk is at the back of
the property which doesn't amend the
layout and the setup of the group of
cottages one thing I would say is a
couple of members have mentioned about
how the rear elevation cannot be seen so
I'd just like to refer back just for
clarity to our conservation officer
comments that
um properties aren't listed for the
public value they're providing so I just
want to sort of mention that so I think
it's probably better to focus on the
initial reasons that that we talked
about but um yeah I'm happy if if you're
of that view that that reflects the
discussion
happy fine by me happy perfect right
let's move to a vote to say the proposal
conditions of course
good it's a good job Amy's here
okay conditions do we have a list of
conditions please
uh yeah so in respect of the full
application for planning permission so
we've got the normal three-year time
limit approved plans materials to be
submitted climate change checklist
parking spaces to be implemented prior
to first use of the extension and also
an additional condition to prevent the
use of the single story roof aspect as a
balcony so that's for the full
application for the list of building
consent it would be uh three years limit
approved plans materials to be submitted
and large-scale details to be submitted
thank you very much happy with that hang
on hang on a second cancer off
you happy with those yes thank you chair
marvelous Council off now you can come
in sorry Alice can you just reiterate
what you said about the balcony please
of course so um if the plan that we're
sharing here so that they're not
proposing a proper balcony across the
single story projecting element it's
just a Juliet Balcony so just a glazing
flush with that rare roof slope with the
two doors
um so we would just be minded to
condition that they can't use that
single story projection as a balcony
okay we have a proposal it has been
seconded we've gone through the
conditions I think we can go for a vote
so the Roses to Grant against officer
recommendation for the reasons given and
of course with those conditions can I
show hands those in favor of granting
eight eight and those against
two those and abstaining one uh that of
course is for the uh the full
application so uh committee results to
Grant application 2203636 ful now for
the LBC could I please have a show of uh
hands in favor of granting
eight and those against
two and abstentions one
marvelous okay committee therefore
resolves to Grant application
2203637 LBC members we've been going for
an hour and a half do you want a quick
Comfort break
yep okay we've got three minutes for a
comfort break
two zero three five six nine fuel Meadow
house in ships and OnStar operating
officer is once again excuse me once
again Malvina it's yak
I
thank you chairman uh so my next
application is
um for a change of views
um
of home office to a holiday let and the
application site is a local new dwelling
that was approved under the application
um
19 slash uh well never mind the
reference in 2019
and the site is located in darling Scott
there is a concert as you can see on on
this plan the conservation area is to
the north of the application site and
there are also listed buildings
um that surround that are scattered
around the application site as well
um planning permission in 2021 was
granted for a householder extension to
link the originally approved detached
garage with the main house
um and home office
was approved
here you can see the application site
within the wider wider area
um
darling's coat
so I already explained that the
application is for a change of views
um and on this slide you can see the
existing plans so
the householder extension to link the
detached garage with the main house was
implemented and you can see this
on the existing plans here
and the next slide shows internal
alterations on the first floor of the
garage
that changed the layout from home office
to one bed holiday LED and this includes
here is one bedroom and Suite and Living
Kitchen
so this is the existing house
here you can see the drive
and the neighboring property to the to
the east
and here you can see the entrance to the
property
um chairman the recommendation is to
Grant the application for the reasons
detailed within the committee report
thank you Malvina thank you very much
our one and only speaker is councilor
Harvey councilor Holly come on down
you know the drill five minutes give you
30 second warning when you're come from
ready to go the floor is yours
thank you Mr chairman
the pointer issue in considering this
application is I suggest whether or not
there was justification for the
imposition of a condition on the
property concerning holiday and whether
there's consistency in decision making
in relation to this development the
essential reason this development of a
three-bedroom dwelling with a double
garage was granted planning consent in
2019 was because it was a local needs
application
approved on the basis that it met a
justifiable local need and therefore
fell within the terms of cs-15g and
as10a the local needs basis of this
approval was demonstrated by the need
for a section 106 agreement
it's critical however to recall how the
section 106 agreement defined a
qualifying household
the agreement states that this term
means in the case of the local Market
unit a single household
provided that such house households
shall at all times include at least one
member who will reside in the local
Market unit as their Sole and permanent
residents who benefits from a local
connection this application was approved
therefore on the basis that the unit was
to be occupied by a single household
subsequently the owner's sought and was
granted permission for an extension to
leak the garage to the dwelling and for
a first four floor extension over the
permitted but yet to be completed garage
to come to create space for a home
office
the home office space can now be
accessed either internally in under by
an unjoining bedroom or externally via a
separate staircase
condition five to this permission
stipulated critically that the office
space is only to be used in a way that
was ancillary to the main dwelling
specifically it stated that it shall not
be used as a separate dwelling unit or
as a unit of holiday accommodation or
for any trade commercial or business use
and no separate cartilage shall be
created while the case officer may now
assert that the reason for condition 5
in relation to the application
concerning the office space was so the
local planning Authority could have
better control over future users of this
space that is not the reason given in
the relevant decision letter
the reason given in the decision letter
was it is considered the site is
inappropriate for an independent unit of
permanent residential or holiday
accommodation or for any commercial or
business use in addition to the main
dwelling and such development would be
detrimental to the amenities of the area
and sustainability objectives in this
rural location having regard to policy
cs1 920 as10 of the core strategy let me
therefore join up the dots the applicant
has now submitted three related
applications in a deliberate sequence
over a relatively short period of time
the essential basis for the approval of
the initial application for this
dwelling was for the proven local need
with the support of 27 local residents
the ward member and the parish council
during construction the second
application was to create the office
space for ancillary use as part of the
dwelling and now we have the third
application to allow holiday makers to
occupy part of this local needs
Justified dwelling
have any of the 24 27 supporting
residents or the ward member or the
parish council given their support to
this application no none of them have
all four of the residents who have on
this occasion provided their written
opinions have objected to it therefore
there is no local support for this
holiday accommodation application
consent for a change of use to allow the
current Office Space over the garage the
garage which was an integral element of
the original application for a dwelling
now to be used at holiday accommodation
by members of the general public would
conflict with the terms of the section
106 agreement
unless varied by agreement between the
parties the terms of the section 106
agreement should be upheld by this
committee a dwelling that was permitted
in circumstances where it normally would
not have been in order to meet a local
housing need and which is required to be
occupied by a single household should be
occupied by a single household this
application in law and inequity should
therefore be refused thank you Mr
chairman
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for Council are we
please cancel Crump first
hello councilor Harvey um three and a
bit questions a very brief one to
everything are there any other holiday
let's nearby
are you aware of a pressing need for
such holiday let's
um are you basically saying the proposal
will change the character of The Village
and just to make it absolutely clear
there's no local support for this
could you give in one by one an online
any other holiday that's nearby
all right
can you define for me what you may mean
by nearby uh within within a mile
I don't know of any uh holiday
accommodation within darling Scott yeah
and thank you I mean there's no there's
no Pub
um there is a church
but there's no school there's no post
office I'm not I'm not aware of any
other holiday comedy I'm I'm not saying
I think you've answered the question I'm
not aware
um second one was are you aware of any
pressing need for such holiday lights in
down that's good
uh no but to be fair I'm not the Arbiter
on that all right and the last one is
um
I'll pump myself off there
um about the proposal change of
character of The Village
um I think the the balanced answer to
that is that this house
which has got permission
does change the the the nature of the
village somewhat it the conservation
area in darling Scott is is indicated
the bar the boundary is that road
um the if you'd been here three years
ago four years ago you would have found
sheep in that field
um so it's the house that's that's
changed the nature of the uh of the area
slightly uh if if the office space over
the garage was used as a was used as
holiday accommodation
apart from the traffic in and out I
don't think it would that would be a
material difference that's obviously not
the basis of my grounds for refusing
Council Parry please
thank you um councilor Harvey you made
reference in your
um presentation with regard to the
section 106 agreement to the original
pla um Planning Commission given but in
accordance with the officer's report on
page 40 the fourth paragraph down
um the office of states the proposed
change of use of the extension to a
holiday let accommodation is not
restricted by the section 106 agreement
attached to the original planning
application could I have your there for
your views in respect of that particular
comment in the officers report
well I have got a copy of the section
106 agreement and I just do not
understand how that view has been come
to
the the words of of what how a single
household and the requirement for a
single household is set out in the in in
the document
Council Rolf please oh so uh it was
cancer off wasn't it yes it was cancer
off please thank you thank you chair um
councilor Harvey so
um at the moment
the garage extension is used as a garage
downstairs and an office upstairs are
you aware or do you have any reason to
believe that it is being used as a
holiday let
so in other words is this is is this a
retrospective application
or or
not
I haven't been inside the property I
don't know whether it's being used as an
office or as a holiday that I have no
grounds for thinking that it is being
used as a holiday land and nobody from
the local area
has told me to that effect and I do have
The Neighbor Next Door
um
has has complained to me on other
grounds before now he hasn't complained
on this ground
okay any other questions for councilor
Harvey please no in that case count
sorry thank you very much for your time
contribution members let's move to
points of clarification or officers
councilor Parry first
thank you I wonder whether officers can
confirm the situation regarding the
section 106 agreement with reference
um to that it is not restrict it doesn't
have any restriction to Holiday lets
given that's a legal question I shall
call our sister in on that one Amy if
you wouldn't mind
am I up there we go mum and yeah so the
sex 106 agreement was completed in June
2019 so it was prior to the application
for the extension
so it didn't cover the extension and it
wasn't varied to cover the extension so
it only covers the dwelling
so the dwelling must remain local needs
all the definitions will apply it must
be occupied by a qualifying person but
it doesn't apply to the extension
councilor crumb please
yeah I think again another framing um
councilor Harvey mentioned a decision
notice
um
and that did seem to reference
no holiday letter form if I'm reading
that right that is
so how does that affect this application
uh yeah so councilor Harvey was quite
right so when we granted the uh
application for the extension with the
ancillary home office we um put it
subject to a standard ancillary
condition now that's very normal the
application would have been submitted as
a household replication
um so basically there's no subdivision
of the plot there's no new planning unit
created so it's um common practice that
we attach a condition to make sure that
it is uh retained for the purposes that
were considered under the household or
application
the reason for the condition is stated
so if I just say it um as it is just for
the avoidance of um doubt so it the
reason for that ancillary condition is
it is considered that the site is
inappropriate for an independent unit of
permanent residential or holiday
accommodation or for any commercial or
business use in addition to the main
dwelling and such development would be
detrimental to the immunities of the
area and sustainability objectives in
this rural location contrary to policy
what I will say is that that reason is
written very poorly the truth of it is
is that we didn't consider at that point
a using that unit as an independent unit
of accommodation or a holiday lap
because that wasn't what was applied for
through that householder process so um
putting our hands up it is a poor reason
for the condition uh the purpose of this
application is to assess whether a
holiday let is appropriate having regard
to local and National policies and for
the reason set out in the report we
considered that the provision of a
holiday let in this location does accord
with policies and that would override
that that previous condition
okay any other questions or points of
clarification members no let's move to
debate if you'd like to kick us off
Council Dixon
thank you chairman
the extension uh to my mind is an
integral part of the property
and it was never to be a separate unit
and it isn't a separate unit
it is part of the property it is
ancillary I would regard the 106 as
covering the whole
property and the intention probably that
106 was intended to cover that whole
property even if a subsequent extension
didn't make reference to it at the
particular time so I must admit I am
very supportive of the view taken by
councilor Harvey and I'm not going to be
supporting this application I should uh
certainly wish to see this one refused
oh was that proposal just some clear
yes happy to recommend refusal chairman
okay we'll come back for some more
detailed reasonings in a moment cancer
Crump please yeah I must admit I'm not
particularly happy with this one I'm
happy to Second uh and
yeah um we'll think of some conditions
or reasons for for refusal but I'm happy
to Second refusal
okay anyone else cancer Mills
yeah I mean I think we said it all I'm
I'm not happy with someone either so
I would go against the office of
recommendation Mr chairman thank you
Council curses
agreeing with that and I I think the
point that Council Harvey raised about
consistency of decision making I think
with his words I think that's also
important to consider when we're making
our decisions okay I can't understood
anyone else
cancer Parry oh sorry it was Catherine I
am so sorry you did you put your hand up
I nodded and then I ignored you I am
terribly sorry cancer is a lot
um I'm of an opposing view I I think as
as uh our solicitor pointed out it only
covers the dwelling the section 106. I
don't see any material planning reasons
to go against the decision to Grant so
I'm
opposite sorry is that a proposal the
opposite way yeah thank you very much
councilor Perry
thank you chairman
May our second councilor Eden's proposal
um
purely on the basis of the the office's
comprehensive report and also the
solicitors response to the section 106
agreement which denotes to the to the
dwelling house
um
noting on the
um layout and pictures of of where the
property is there are clear extensive
separation distances between this
property and the neighboring properties
and therefore I don't feel and there's
there's ample parking
um accommodation
um we are meant to be developing
economic growth across the district
tourism is
dare I say Stratford District Council
was the fourth worst hit District as a
result of the pandemic
um
it's it the holiday let isn't just about
the owners it provides opportunities for
villagers perhaps to get involved in
terms of servicing providing maintenance
so I think there's some economic growth
plus points here but most importantly
the solicitor has confirmed technical
reasons why we need to abide
um
by the section 106 agreement I
understand totally that this is a local
needs but in fact that it's not as
though the property has been sold on a
commercial basis we still have the
people living in the detached property
um and I think we should be promoting
tourism
um particularly if counselor Harvey says
he he doesn't he's not aware of any
holiday let
um facilities in the area
so I'm happy to Second counselor Eden's
proposal to Grant thank you chair thank
you very much Council Kendall please
thank you councilor Perry has said
pretty much everything I wanted to say
so I won't rehash it but for me I think
that we are supposed to be finding
um economic benefits and I think there's
loads of economic benefits to the to the
district more widely with this
application and I think this be perfect
for for a holiday let's I will be
supportive Grant
Council Rolf please
um
I would agree with councilor Perry and
others at the proposal I don't think
really we have any reasons to actually
uh go against the officer's
recommendation at all
okay thank you very much anyone else
wants to contribute to debate before or
cancel the Crump
let's come back in I
I think the tourism one is is probably
slightly far-fetched um one holiday let
in a unsustainable location with no
services in that Village I think the
economic benefit is exaggerated and I
think the harm will cause it will cause
or outweigh these benefits and its
interest in the market hasn't provided
any normally a market provides a
response to a need and if there's no
other holiday let's in the occasion in
the surrounding era I I don't think any
economic argument stands up it could be
a flood of holiday let's now if this one
gets approved you never know councilor
Dixon you had a hand up
I did Chairman thank you let me come
back
um my emphasis is merely the fact that
the property wouldn't have existed if it
hadn't been for a local need if that had
been just a private house from the very
start I wouldn't have any problem
but it was specifically agreed as a
local property a local use I appreciate
that local residents are in half of the
property and the part that's the major
but ultimately it's their local property
and it should not have been going along
this route and I think the 106 would be
to my mind would Encompass the whole but
there we are
okay
uh anyone else before we move to a vote
no okay so I'm on it
um
we do need to clarify your clear reasons
why you're going against the officer's
recommendation and looking to refuse so
could you please in very clear and
concise terms tell me what those are
the use of the ancillary accommodation
for Holiday accommodation is
inappropriate to that
to the basis on which the property was
originally granted consent as a local
domestic property for local use just so
we're clear the local need a designation
for that property won't change if this
were granted
should I potentially have a different
reason
yeah would you like to withdraw your
proposal then no
you're welcome Council Crump yeah it's
the second day I think that
um it's not a sustainable light location
uh it will change the character of The
Village uh
because there are no hot lady that's in
that Village
um
and there's potential
um loss of privacy insecurity concerns
as well so
I hope they are a bit more robust
I'm going to ask our planning manager to
respond
um if I could just devise on on the
reasons firstly put forward by councilor
Dixon for um Council of um Richard
saying that local East dwelling will
remain is the case so I think we're on
sticky territory to say that that's a
reason to refuse the application turning
to councilor crumps points
um obviously for reasons set out in the
officer's report it is considered to be
a sustainable location for a tourism use
but appreciating that members may not
agree with that interpretation of the
policy so I think not a sustainable
location and will change the character
of The Village
um a legitimate in terms of potential
loss of privacy and security concerns I
didn't hear that picked up in the debate
and I'm conscious that there's there's
quite a separation distance to
residential property so I wonder well
actually if you can see on here uh the
proximity of the site to neighbors
um obviously happy to go with that if
you maintain that reason but I just
wanted to flag that separation distance
being more than sufficient in officers
view to make the privacy and security
issues not a concern
I can see the way that probably the the
meeting is going but um happy for the
first two and if the third one uh
regardless security and previously I'm
I'm happy to withdraw that
okay uh Constitution just to check
you're happy with that proceed of the
reasons Council Crump you're happy we do
of course have to take that proposal
first because that was the first one was
made so could I please have a show of
hands for those in favor of refusing
this application for the reason it's
given
four
and those against
six and abstentions none so that has
failed um we of course had a proposal to
Grant in line with officer
recommendation made by councilor Ed and
seconded by councilor Parry could I have
a show of hands for those in favor of
granting
six against
four abstentions silch so committee
therefore resolves two Grant application
in reference
2203569 fuel metal house in Dallas get
thank you very much let's move to our
next application which is application
reference
2203384ful one Hill Lane in Upper
Quentin obsidian officer is Stuart
mcgiver
Stuart as soon as you're set ready and
comfortable to go the floor is yours
yeah thank you chairman good evening
everyone
so the proposal before members is change
of use of detached owl building from
ancillary accommodation to Holiday
Cottage at one Hill Lane Upper Quinton
which you can see denoted by the black
dot uh Illustrated on the map on the
screen
so we have the application site is
outlined in red it is to the southern
outskirts of the settlement of upper
Quinton you have adjacent residential
development on both sides
so we have the existing site plan which
illustrates the uh the outbuilding here
to the far rear of the plot
and then we have the proposed site plan
which again illustrates the existing
outbuilding far away of plots so we have
uh also the access for the path to the
side of the application site and you
also have the parking provision to the
front
so we have existing and proposed
elevations
um these do not
uh show at any external alterations to
the to the existing out building
so then we go on to existing air
proposed floor plans so with the
proposed floor plan on the right hand
side the only difference is the
introduction of a kitchen area
so then we go on to just a couple of
site images so this first site image is
taken from Hill Lane itself and is
facing towards the host dwelling and you
can see the parking area to the front
here
and then we go on to another site image
so this is taken from
Hill Lane itself and it is looking
Northwest across the rear Garden of the
adjacent property and you can see the
existing owl building as it's situated
here
um you can sort of see to the map on the
right hand side with the arrow which
denotes the
um Direction the the photos taken from
uh so in summary the proposed
development involves a reuse of an
existing building resulting in a small
scale two-bedroom holiday let the
application site is located within
proximity to nearest numerous tourist
attractions including golf courses
public houses and public footpaths which
are considered tourist attractions
as such a proposed change of use of the
owl building from ancillary
accommodation to a holiday Cottage is
considered to comply with the relevant
provisions of policies as10s and cs24
and it is therefore recommended the
planning permissions granted thank you
chairman sure thank you very much indeed
we'll call our first speaker on
entertainment who's councilor Edward
fitter of Quentin Parish Council
good evening councilor fitter thank you
for your patience once you're seated and
comfortable you'll have three minutes I
will give you a 30 second warning for
your time is up but as soon as you're
ready and set to go the floor is yours
great thank you chair and good evening
everyone so I'm also a Queensland Parish
counselor and the parish council has
asked me to represent them as well on
this occasion I also made an objection
with my Stratford District councilor hat
on as well
so the app an application for this site
was made
um in October 2018 uh where the annex
was for a workshop and storage in 2019
it then changed to include a bedroom and
sitting area
the planning decision was issued back in
January 2020 and was the annex hereby
permitted shall only be used
for additional living accommodation
incidiary to the enjoyment of the main
dwelling known as one Hill Lane it
should not be used as a separate
dwelling unit with the reasoning that
the site isn't appropriate for an
independent unit a permanent
accommodation in addition to the main
dwelling and search development would be
detrimental to the immunities of the
area and sustainability objectives in
this rural location having regards
policy cs1 cs9 cs20
and as10 of the core strategy
so the unit is already online as a
holiday Cottage and has reviews going
back to October 2020 and there are other
holiday lets in the area as well
so this new application as we saw states
that there's space for four cars from my
knowledge of that site
that would have to include the public
footpath as well
um so very simply from myself and
Quentin Parish Council is nothing has
changed from the application back in
it previously had restrictions for
Holiday use and nothing has changed with
this so for a now to be granted it
doesn't make sense
um and someone who looks at the last
application is we kind of needed his
consistency with decision making thank
you Joe
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for councilor fitter
remember he will be coming back as a
board member later councilor Crump
Ultron raised a couple of points to do
with the parish council um firstly the
status of Quentin Parish council's
neighborhood plan has that been to
referendum
yes it was approved at the last four
council meeting brilliant thought it
rang about uh anything he says anything
in the
thing about holiday cottages
particularly in that location
not that I can recall
okay
Council Ralph please
uh yes so um
councilor fitted you can confirm that
this has been used as a holiday Cottage
yes
I think so so just going on the holiday
sites
um it's got reviews going back to
October 2020 from from customers okay
okay objecting to this yes thank you
councilor Perry please thank you chair I
think councilor Rolf has asked the
questions I was going to ask but can I
just ask councilor fitter has this
application been has it come forward as
a result of an enforcement
um concern which is why there is there
the application has come forward for
retrospective
uh not that I'm aware of
okay
um any other questions for cancer
further as Parish Council Representative
no marvelous cancer thank you very much
Tom contribution thank you I won't be
coming back as District rep that was the
main one oh that was it I've got you
registered again so you've got another
five minutes if you want okay
in that case we will call our next
speaker who is the agent of the
application Miss Miranda Rogers
Mrs
I was being blank but perfect
yeah
um so uh Miranda you've got three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
before your time is up floor is yours
right hand side
now is this system it's great
um towards the end of 2019 the applicant
received planning permission to replace
out buildings at the end of her garden
with a new building she completed the
work shortly after and began using it
for purposes ancillary to the main house
in March 2020 the covid pandemic arrived
and the applicant lost her job given her
advancing years she was unable to find a
new one and with her husband having long
since retired she looked at Instead at
alternative ways to supplement her
pension using the outbuilding to
generate an income seemed like a logical
solution and notwithstanding the
restrictive condition that you've heard
of she proceeded to let the building as
a self-contained holiday cottage from
October 2020 your Enforcement Officers
visited the site identified the breach
and requested the building seats being
used as a holiday Cottage until planning
permission was granted the applicant
willingly complied with this and the use
stopped in at the end of September 2021
Steins Gate then prepared an application
that you now have before you
your Parish Council and District
councilor have concluded the scheme must
be unacceptable because there is a
restrictive condition attached to the
previous permission which prevents the
holiday Cottage use of the building
this interpretation is inaccurate the
applicant previously sought permission
for an incidental domestic outbuilding
and the application was determined on
that basis the condition limiting future
use as your officers report outlines and
you heard in respect to the previous
application considered tonight was not
applied because other uses were
unacceptable it's a badly worded
standard condition applied because other
uses had not been considered an
imposition of such a condition would
allow any alternative use to be properly
considered at the appropriate time this
is that appropriate time
the application site lies within the
built up area boundary for upper Quinton
where the core strategy supports the
creation of holiday Cottages the
neighborhood plan similarly supports the
ReUse of existing buildings within buabs
I believe it's policy h01 the principle
of The Proposal is therefore policy
compliant we then have to consider
site-specific matters your office's
report provides a detailed assessment of
these and concludes that the scheme is
entirely acceptable I will draw your
attention just to highways because it's
raised by the parish council the
submitted drawings show there is ample
room within the site to accommodate four
cars and a secure cycle store which
Accords with part o of your development
requirements SBD there is no objection
from County highways confirming the
scheme will not have an adverse impact
on highway safety 30 seconds the parking
spaces do not overhang the public
footpath overall The Proposal complies
with the development plan and there are
no material considerations which
indicate an alternative view should be
taken and I therefore ask that you grant
planning permission in accordance with
your officer's recommendation
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions councilor Perry
please
thank you good evening Miranda
um are you aware of any objections from
the neighboring properties whilst the
holiday let
um was was in operation and secondly
um can you explain why it's 18 months
ago since the enforcement action that a
as it's taken 18 months for a planning
application to come forward
terms of neighbor objections I'm not
aware of any certainly no objections
were submitted in respect of this
application
in terms of the length of time between
the enforcement action and the
submission of the application I believe
the enforcement action was
raised in the summer last summer so I
don't know exactly which month possibly
June or July at which time there were
bookings within the system and there was
an agreement between the enforcement
team and the owner that they could
continue with the bookings and they
stopped those at the end of September
and the enforcement case was
subsequently closed and I have got
written evidence of that
thank you very much Council Rolf
I think I'm Gonna Save my question for
clarification later thank you okay
anyone else have any questions for Mrs
Rogers sorry Council Crump
um
right yeah hi um
you mentioned the neighborhood plan
um to do with holiday Cottages I believe
can I could you repeat what you said
about that please uh asking around about
quinton's neighborhood plan
quinton's neighborhood plan has two
built-up area boundaries
um one for upper one for lower this site
lies within the upper Quinton built a
ferry boundary policy in the
neighborhood plan doesn't specifically
refer to Holiday Cottages but it does
specifically refer to the conversion of
existing buildings
and if you put that in line with the
policies in the core strategy which
support the conversion of buildings
within built of area boundaries to
Holiday Cottages than we are policy
compliant
sort of very clearly policy compliance
okay
thank you
members do we have any other questions
please Mrs Rogers thank you very much
for time contribution this evening let's
move to points clarification Council
Rolf
um yes so can you
I'm a little confused here because
Miranda said that at the point of
enforcement there was
about it being used as a holiday
accommodation uh they came to an
agreement that because there were
bookings
the holiday accommodation could continue
provided that a retrospective
application was put forth is that
correct
I think it's fair to say that we as
officers can't confirm the timeline of
the enforcement advice
um what I would say is the applications
come in we've assessed it on its own
merits and so I can't confirm or deny
but it sounds reasonable that it is
something that our enforcement team
would advise but I can't confirm either
way
cancel Crump yeah some uncertainty about
how the council was made or aware of the
potential breach
um
have you any idea who who made the
Council of the way was it a neighbor or
um so I'm very conscious the fact that
we seem to be hung up on
um an alleged breach and an enforcement
action that is not relevant to the
decision-making of an application that's
in front of us it might have happened we
don't know the details of it but the
reality is we have to make a decision on
the application that is put in front of
us now based on our policies so I'm
going to move forward from the
enforcement details and we are going to
ask questions if we can please about the
actual application councilor Rolf
uh yes could you uh show me a picture of
where or can you illustrate how forecast
can park please
according to highways for Carlton Park
here
and where
yeah so as you can see on the proposed
site plan you have the uh
scale site plan I should add you can see
where the four cars are parked here
again I I can reiterate the County
Council highways were
consulted as part of the plan
application didn't raise any objections
in terms of Highway Safety
um I I I'm just gonna throw it
out here that I find it I find it odd
because is this a question or a
statement because if it's a statement
you can save it for debate
okay
thank you councilor Harvey
thank you Mr chairman
um in relation to the 2019 application
there was a condition which we've
accepted is a not the best word
condition which makes reference to four
policies as a as a reason for for
inserting that condition
um two of those are two of those grounds
are covered either responded to I cs9
and as20 as10 in in the officer's report
but cs1 cs20 are basis for objections uh
basis for the imposition of the
condition condition four in the 2019
application and there is no reference to
to how can policy cs1 and cs20 have been
complied with to overcome that that
condition why are those admitted
um through you chairman
um as you know we don't refer to every
single policy in our committee reports
having said that I appreciate that
there's some relevance given that it was
quoted in the the original application
um so in terms of cs1 that talks about
um
sustainable development so obviously in
respect of the principal section as set
out within the report it talks about
as10 now the purpose of as10 is to
identify those forms of development
which are appropriate for Countryside
and Village locations so to my mind the
the fact that it complies with as10 it
by default complies with cs1 because we
haven't identified any other harm in any
other respects that would
say that okay the sustainable the
location's okay and sustainable but all
these other things are unacceptable but
actually as a whole it's considered that
the application Accords with cs1 because
it Accords with our planning policies
generally particularly as10
so that's that one if you're happy
uh I can accept that as an explanation
I'd also suggest it would the report
would have been improved if that had
been made clear
that is noted in respect of cs20 it
relates to existing housing stock and
buildings and it talks about conversions
of changes of use and it essentially
says that the existing housing stock
would manage and safeguarded proposals
will not result in the net loss of
dwellings through demolition or change
of use unless there is a specific and
overriding reason and obviously in this
case we're not losing the dwelling we're
just adding a holiday let within the
existing outbuilding
I repeat it would have been better if
the media Point has been made and I
think taken them on board uh do we have
any other points of clarification no
let's move into debate I'm going to
assume the council Rolf would like to
make a statement now
um yeah I I I have concerns about the
four cars I mean you know I've I've
dealt with many planning applications
where highways have said you have to be
able to turn your car
within the room in order to come out
frontways and looking at that I can't
see any of those cars being able to do
that I'm just saying that it's it's
often been an argument in a planning
application and people have accepted
that from highways so I slightly doubt
their integrity and saying that you can
turn a car within that cartilage
yeah
councilor Adam please
thank you chair
um
I do record a little bit with the with
the parking comments
um and and the way that the the site is
laid out but
um that looks less than ideal for me if
I was going to go to a holiday let but
that's not the point
um
it feels very similar to what we were
dealing with in the last application
although it is obviously a very
different
um application itself in terms of what
it's doing
um and councilor fitter asked for
consistent decision making so I'm going
to propose that we go for Grant on this
because
um for me I can still see no material
planning reasons why how we could resist
this
thank you very much Council Dixon next
please thank you chairman
um I don't think there's been any policy
changes since the uh approval was given
for these uh ancillary outbuildings and
therefore my assumption is that if uh
back in uh 20 uh was it 2019 an
application was made to create a holiday
let at the bottom of the garden it would
equally well have met with a support
from the officers and approval
potentially because I don't see anything
changing within our own planning
guidance it's the only difference being
that our policy now allows for buildings
which exist to be converted
whereas obviously in 2019 they didn't
exist until we actually gave them
permission as an ancillary building so I
must admit I'm not minded to support
this one for the simple reason
that uh
I don't think if it had been the
application had come forward a few years
ago as a holiday we would have supported
it and I think we might now be
supporting it because it's being used as
a holiday let an enforcement action as
created an application coming before us
thank you very much I think you might
have misphrased your earlier statement
there because your final statement
contradicted your first statement but
I'm going to take your last statement as
your actual thought process councilor
Perry next please
thank you chair
um
from my perspective we have no
objections from neighboring properties
um to to the property being used as a
holiday let
I think the fact that there have been a
number of bookings highlights there is a
demand
for a holiday let operation in this area
which conforms to policy cs24 tourism
and Leisure developments it also
conforms to policy cs22 in terms of
economic growth
the property lies within the built up
area boundary there are no additions
extensions to the outbuilding and
therefore I'm happy to Second counselor
Eden's proposal
the marvelous thank you very much
Council Curtis please
thank you um
the permission was granted in January on
the condition that it shall not be used
as separate dwelling you the holiday
accommodation Etc
I'm just slightly concerned I'm not sure
which way I'm going to to vote on this
but I am concerned that in this and the
previous application
um about the the standard conditions and
Mrs Rogers said you know it was a badly
worded standard condition and I just
wonder if this would be an opportunity
in future to look at the wording of
those conditions you'll be pleased to
know that's already happened as you
heard earlier there has been an
acceptance that the wording was poor the
reasoning I think the wording of the
reason was poor it has already been
adjusted for future
so thank you uh Council Kendall next
please keep it brief counselor Perry
said everything again for me I will be
supporting the application councilor
Crump please
I'll go from consistency of decision
making and I'll be consistent with my
previous points um that
there's been um allegedly no objections
from Neighbors but there's been strong
uh objections from both the parish
council and then I put plan which they
spent time on
and also from the Ward member so on our
back localism and local need and local
opinion and I think councilor to decide
to cancel the role it was a unanimous
decision by the parish council
um so I will be object into this one
okay thank you very much Council Foreman
thank you
um I support councilor Eden and
councilor Parry in their comments
there's been no objection from Neighbors
and we have policies that support
tourism and Leisure development so I
will be supporting the application
thank you very much indeed okay I think
we're only missing two speakers
otherwise we have a full house but I
think we can probably unless you
desperately want to say something cancer
Mills good
um we have a proposal to Grant by cancer
edin secondly by councilor Perry that
was the first proposal that was put so
could I please have a show of hands for
those in favor of Grant and inline with
the officer recommendation
seven and those against
two abstentions
two uh okay in that case committee
resolves to Grant application 2203384
ful one Hill Lane in Upper Clinton
let's move to our final application of
the evening which is application
reference
22.03 706 f u l the old Cottage in
tanworth and Arden the
all costumes in terms of Northern our
presentation officer is Emily Booker
Emma Booker crikey I'm tripping over my
own tongue tonight Emma whenever you're
sat Comfort ready to go it's over to you
thank you chair
um today I am presenting a proposal for
the erection of a three-bed detached
dwelling in Wood end in the Tamworth
Garden neighborhood plan area
so it's going to be built to the front
of a dwelling named the old Cottage the
site is outlined in red on that map
before you
the dwelling is to be built within the
domestic cartilage of the old Cottage
and the application has been made on the
basis that this represents Limited
infill in a green belt location
this map shows the application site with
the black dot you can see it here it's
in Wood end to the north of tanworth in
Arden the M40 Motorway is visible there
in blue to the north so we're right at
the top of the district here
this is a aerial photo to show the
context of the application site which is
circled in red you can see Broad Lane
and the prevailing character of
residential dwellings in that vicinity
opposite the site you've got the
Warwickshire lad Public House
on this next map or area photo should
say I've zoomed in so that you can see
the proximity of the application site to
neighboring properties to the West
you've got a neighbor called Marvin
to the South you've got the the
applicant's property and then to the
east you've got Hardwick house
and then obviously to the north you've
got the public house as well
before you you can see the proposed
plans you've got the proposed elevations
at the top
uh on the left hand side you've got our
proposed floor plans you can see that
the dwelling is an L shape
with the res with the garden would be in
that gap between
what yeah it's obvious you can see from
the proposed site plan as well
um the proximity to Marvin
that neighbor to the west you can also
see that there's our street parking
provided for two cars they're going to
share and access with the old Cottage
um yeah and I will say that we've
received an amendment throughout the
course of the application which has
varied the design of the proposed
dwelling at the request of officers
so this plan was provided by the
architect to emphasize that The Proposal
complies with our tests on the 25 45
degree so we've concluded that the new
dwelling would have an acceptable impact
on the immunity of the neighbors
um you can ask me questions on this
later but we we consider that The
Proposal complies with our SPD with
regard to separation distances and we
have proposed conditions to also
mitigate the impact on that closest
neighbor
so photos now so you can this is the
view into and out of the site from Broad
Lane
this is um the adjacent neighbor as well
closest to the dwelling the dwelling is
being built on the other side of that
quite dense bout of vegetation there so
it's it's sitting behind that screening
the street scene now which is the public
house
um you can see that there's a there's a
verdant character
um reflective of its kind of rural
Village location
I'm standing in the site now
um so you can see that that that's where
the new dwelling is proposed at the
front there
this this tree that you can see the
middle of the site with the tape around
it that's proposed to be removed
so this one just demonstrates again the
proximity to neighbor
um and you're looking back towards the
applicant's house now
again just more photos the one on the
right is um the neighbor to the east
which is some distance away
and that concludes my presentation thank
you
Emma thank you very much indeed let's
call our first Speaker who is councilor
Sanders from Tamworth in Arden Parish
Council
good evening councilor thank you for
your patience
I think you've got an idea of the drill
so you'll have three minutes I'll give
you 30 second warning before your time
is up otherwise whenever you're ready if
you press the button on the right
time is yours
okay yeah thank you right
we only have one major concern with this
application we accept that it's in the
built up area boundary and therefore in
principle development should be allowed
our concern is it does not fit with the
setting it's out of considerably out of
character with the area around it
broad raid is characterized by large
houses in large plots set well back from
the road and quite strong tree lines in
most places on the boundary of the road
if you look at your map with the back of
your agenda
this plot this house will sit right next
to Marvin
um and be quite out of keeping with the
main principal building lines who look
down this side of Broadway and the other
side
and it just occurred to me actually
before I came here that there is an
application to knock Marvin down which
is a Victorian date it's not insanely
same age as the rest of the housing in
which case what's your proposing a grant
permission for will be the only house
sitting right on the edge of the highway
we also have mentioned in our objection
over development by that I think we mean
that this is incredibly tight little
piece of development out of character
with the rest of the area
and although it may or may reach your
minimum standards that doesn't
necessarily mean to say those are the
right standards for Broad Lane
and that is the main point I want to
make here
very good thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for our
Parish Council
no
in that case thank you very much your
patience and your time and contributions
if you need to speed up at this time
yeah good man
okay let's call our next speaker who is
Mr Gibson
good evening Mr Gibson thank you very
much your patience uh choose any seat
with a microphone
and when your sound come from ready to
go you'll have three minutes I'll give
you a 30 second warning if you press the
button on the right the floor will be
yours
bear with and we'll get them up
you'll give us a nod when you want the
slides changing will you
you just want them rotating as we're as
you're talking okay
we're just going to pull them up
okay whenever you're ready to flow is
yours
if you can press the button on the right
sorry thank you can you hear me yeah you
can lovely thank you
um I'm the owner of Marvin the uh rear
of my property directly faces the land
proposed for development the old Cottage
on the screen now you can see a direct
view from my house
I'm not anti-development but there is a
reason why planning policies exist
and they must be adhered to which is why
I purchased this property back in
December
two prior applications were made on this
site both were drawn my objection is
based on residential immedity Part F of
spt clearly sets out separation
distances to protect loss of privacy
overshadowing and overbearing
I wasn't able to sorry I was unable to
include an attachment of this but table
F1 stipulates the accepted separation
distances
back to rear is 30 meters The Proposal
is three and a half meters at the
closest point and 11 meters at the
furthest point the latter being viewed
from the rear window of the master
bedroom
more importantly a habitable room where
people get dressed
I've included pictures that you can see
from that bedroom there
the planning officers said earlier there
was a screen there isn't any screen
between that view and the proposed site
there is also a layout plan this window
directly goes to a ensuite so you'll be
directly walking to and from the ensuite
from that area
um I'm not sure whether the layout plans
are on there of The Proposal but it was
a garden obviously before the main
entrance is just in front of that and
also a side entrance
that area in front of the window is the
main area where people will be outside
using that house
the committee report that was submitted
accepted that this was the rear
elevation of Marvin furthermore there
was awareness from the planning officer
that there will be overlooking as it
suggested obscure glazing and no opener
Windows Windows sorry
are secured by condition so it's
accepted that this is the rear elevation
there is also notice sorry I will also
mention of loss of Lights the officer
makes reference to it an additional plan
that's been submitted
that was submitted by the applicant and
it complies with Part D and SBD which
released a lot of light
the plan that was submitted contains two
photos both taken in the afternoon
my understanding is a 24-hour study is
taken for something like this I've
submitted a photo that was in the
afternoon sorry in the morning
properties to the east there is
overshadowing in the morning
I'll make it quick
they should refuse this application
because it doesn't comply with
Stratford's extrapolation distances
if you were to give the approval I would
like the condition to be that it states
that this should be 13 meters away from
Marvin thank you
spot on thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for Mr
Gibson please
no in that case just give him some thank
you very much for your time and
contribution this evening if you
wouldn't mind turning your microphone
off a game for me that'd be wonderful
thank you very much indeed
okay let's call our next speaker and
this item who is a Mr Andrew Simpson
architect
Mr Simpson thank you again for your
patience as well you will have six
minutes I'll give you 30 second morning
before your time is up otherwise
whenever you're ready press the button
on the right the floor is yours
thank you good evening and thank you for
letting me speak tonight I'm Andrew
Simpson and I'm the architect of this
proposal I represent my client Mr
Bristow who is a local member of the
community living at Old Cottage last
year we made a formal pre-application on
his behalf to ascertain as to whether an
additional property would be acceptable
on the current site as Limited infill
planning officers supported the
principle of the development as Limited
infill at that point and throughout the
process they've given clear feedback and
uh you know we've adhered to that at
every time at every Point we've adear to
local policy and responded to any point
that has been raised by either objectors
or by the case officers and we are
pleased that the case officer is
recommending approval for this site to
respond to the neighbor's comments
firstly the design has been respectful
to Marvin we've used this L shape so
that there are no habitable rooms facing
the Marvin site and as agreed with the
the case officer there will only be
fixed obscure glazing to a whole Space
facing Marvin also we have provided
additional drawings to show that we
comply with both the 45 degree and the
25 degree Rule and that has been agreed
by the planning officer
notwithstanding it's our belief that the
neighbor is objecting purely for
personal financial gain they have
offered to purchase the site on numerous
occasions
uh in writing
um and have only just submitted their
own application on the Marvin land
um so it appears that they want to
acquire this land for their own garden
the Parish Council made reference to
this application the application shows
the Marvin building remaining not being
demolished as far as I'm aware and also
was made after our application so it
doesn't seem fair to judge our
application based on that
um
yeah so for these reasons we don't think
that the neighbors comments hold bearing
and planning policy just to quickly
um add to one point regarding those
photos you were shown the only three
windows at first floor aren't Marvin
facing the North East which would not be
affected by light
two ensuite and a dressing room which
isn't a habitable space that dressing
room you can see clear photos on
rightmove.com for when that when Marvin
was put for sale last year showing that
there is a bedroom with two windows
facing in opposite directions and that
there has been a knock through into that
dressing room it's a tertiary window in
a dressing room so there are no
habitable rooms facing the old Cottage
site at first floor
as regards to the award members comments
um the ward member inquired after where
there was enough immunity space on the
properties and we've submitted a
comprehensive Landscaping plan uh and
planting scheme which improves the
boundary and adds more vegetation to
that boundary
um we've also submitted plans showing
square meters of the immunity space and
we're above what local policy asks for
the ward member also made some comments
regarding the building line the planning
office is pre-application response
accepted that it's appropriate for our
proposal to sit along the building line
of Marvin so long as the proposal was
moved laterally away from Marvin to
avoid any potential terracing effect
which we have achieved with this
L-shaped design
I'm all over as supported by the
agricultural impact assessment that's
been submitting all the existing
vegetation along the road and access
Drive can and will be retained as
screening a condition can be applied if
there are any concerns over tree
retention as we aware a number of trees
have been removed from the Marvin site
in the recent weeks most importantly as
regards to the war members comments as
requested by the uh the planning officer
this is this proposal as you can see
from the top the top right it it's been
designed with two primary elevations it
therefore turns a corner and kind of it
completes the urban realm whereas Marvin
on its own at the moment is in Congress
this is completing the urban realm and
doesn't set a precedent the properties
that we're being referred to are
tens of meters many many meters away
from this property so in urban terms
what we're doing we believe improves the
urban Fabric and on that last Point all
that was left of the the ward members
comments is a is uh he makes reference
to potential future hypothetical
applications and when we feel that
especially with how we've done the
elevations committed to two primary
elevations when we're going what we
believe is above and beyond it doesn't
seem fair for this application to be
judged on anything other than its own
merits
finally just to briefly cover the
correspondence with the planners the
design has undergone Evolution from the
pre-application to announce based on the
correspondence we've had with them the
proper process has been followed
throughout this including the
pre-application and the design does meet
all the local policy guidelines
as hard work we've put in we are pleased
that the the local offices are
recommending this for approval thank you
Mr Simpson thank you very much well
within your time members do we have any
questions for our architect Council
Crump
it's very brief one it says in the
report the minimum separation distances
um
have been satisfied have you if you've
got those separation distances I thought
ask the architecture is likely to know
um at the
without I can't read off that drawing
because it's a too small to scale the
the thing that the things that we're
asked to do was first and foremost is at
the top end of the site we were asked to
move the originally we had uh on the
pre-app a block that was entirely
against the road but that was within
about a meter of the um Marvin we were
asked to move over three meters and
that's what what we have done uh at that
North End of the site
um in terms of the South element of of
the of the design again I can't read off
that plan as to whether we're about it
looks up to me around 30 meters but more
importantly that we were asked to
provide no habitable rooms with Windows
facing the site which we've done we were
asked the height of the proposal be
satisfactory to comply with the 25
degree rule which we've done we've
lowered the height of the building
um and
um we were asked to prove that there was
no 45 degree crash and there isn't any
there but I apologize I can't read as to
whether it's exactly 30 meters just
below or just above we might clarify
that with our officers in a moment any
other questions for our architects no Mr
Simpson thank you very much for your
time and contribution this evening
let's go on Final speaker entertainment
is cancer Dixon
Council Dixon you know the drill five
minutes 30 second warning button on the
right when you're ready it's yours
all right thank you chairman
um councilor Saunders from the council
Parish Council made reference to the
plan at the back
um I shall also make reference to it
um essentially Marvin isn't is an odd
building within Broad Lane it is the
only one that is within a few feet of
Broad Lane itself the building line is
very distinct amongst those large houses
in large plots which essentially is the
feel of the whole area of wood end in
that area
this is the first application I've seen
for somebody to build a new property in
a new dwelling in a front garden
sometimes we talk about battleland
development but this is actually the
front garden of the old Cottage it
doesn't have a rear Garden because
obviously he divots Church view so it is
to a certain extent to my mind trying to
squeeze a three-bedroomed property into
the front garden of a
semi-detached property which it shares
with with church view as such
is it in character with the the local
area well in Truth uh it just is not
um uh design and distinctiveness
obviously we we require uh should be
sensitive to the setting the existing
built form neighboring uses and
Landscape character what is being
proposed doesn't comply with any of cs9
totally against it Etc
um what is uh has led the agents uh the
architect Etc is from the very outset
the planning officers have accepted this
is infill
well uh and infill is permitted within
the green belt okay yes the npf place is
great importance on keeping the green
belt Land open and permanent
paragraph 149 it sets out that the local
planning Authority should regard the
construction of new buildings in the
green belt as inappropriate but there
are allowances I.E limited infill but
Linville infill
not defined in the nppf or in the PPG
and whether a development can be
considered to represent limited
infilling is a matter of planning
judgment
uh the officer's report goes on although
the dwelling is set forward of the old
Cottage let's face it it's in the front
garden it can't be anywhere else other
than in front and forward of the old
Cottage it would follow the building
line established by the side elevation
of Malvern
well Melvin's the only one which is uh
up against the road yes it would follow
that but it would not follow the
building line of all the rest of Broad
Lane but the officer's report goes on to
say that in their opinion it would sit
between Malvern and uh
a and fill a gap in the street scene
well that Gap is between Malvern and the
right of way simply the access to which
that the driver under Road access would
be made to this property if it were
granted that property at that access
obviously covers the existing property
of the old Cottage and and church View
so if I now think about Landscaping the
impact policy CS5 of the course strategy
seeks to maintain the landscape
character and the quality of the
district by ensuring that development
takes place in the manner that minimizes
and mitigates its impact and where
possible incorporates meant
incorporates measures to enhance that
landscape squeezing this little property
into a very little front garden to be
honest is not enhancing anything about
the landscape or the character who would
end this application I am surprised from
the very start that it actually has come
to committee because I would never
regarded infilling by using the front
garden of any property as being
appropriate for in filling purposes and
I would respectfully request that the
committee reject this on the grounds
that it is not limited infill thank you
chairman
thanks very much Council Dixon members
we have any questions for our Ward
member please
no cancel 16 thank you very much
okay uh move to points of clarification
we have already had one about separation
distances so I don't know if you're able
you're happy with the separation
decisions now okay Council off then
please
uh well I quite like the separation
distance is clarified uh can I ask is
this
is this forward of the build line of
Broad Lane
and by how much
so it depends what you would take the
build line from with looking at the map
at the back and mostly they're all yeah
yeah so if I show you
there's a build line established by the
row of properties here
oh
um
I felt that when I was at the site that
build line is not really read with this
site it feels different from that and
the proposal to line up the front
elevation of the proposed running with
Marva and is acceptable because this
we've I felt that this proposed one is
not going to be any more prominent in
the street scene because it doesn't
protrude press but it is
no no it's not it's no closest to the
road
okay the map back shows it Forward may
ask one other question please how big is
the garden of this proposed property
I can't give you an exact measurement
now but we can
86 meters squares 86 meters squared
which is 66 86 which is in excess of our
SBD requirements okay
like any other points of clarification
members let's move to the debate who
would like to kick us off
who am I going to point to councilor
Mills please thanks Mr yeah um a little
bit troubled by this Mr chairman
um
to my mind at the moment I don't think
it fits in with the street scene at the
moment I'm just going to see what other
counselors think on the committee but to
me at the moment it's not fitting with
street scene with me but I'll see what
other people have to say thank you
cancer Parry please
thank you chair
um I think this is quite an interesting
application before as I always think
anything in the green belt is very
interesting
um it certainly is in Phil because it is
between a number of properties
the front elevation of Marvin it's not
in front of that and also
um
opposite the proposed application is the
pub which is again very much forward
compared albeit on the opposite side of
the road where other buildings are
further back so in my view there's no
real consistency in this particular
section of the
um Street Scene
um
whilst I acknowledge most of the
properties in Broad Lane are extremely
large on very large plots
um I actually think it it gives rather a
welcome opportunity to have something a
bit smaller so that
um
a smaller family can actually come and
live in a smaller property in a very
affluent area
I am actually quite prepared to propose
Grant but with a condition that is a
restriction to Holiday lets
late hour is playing with our counselors
Minds uh councilor Kendall please
um
caught me off guard with the holiday
lights
um I won't support the holiday lights
part of that but I I can't find a reason
to go to go against is I take Council
Mill's point about it not fitting but I
don't think there is a uniformity to the
streets in that area just it's not
striking me as being particularly
uniform this isn't there's not a row of
um semi-detached or whatever it's a
unique setting and the same is true for
the houses they're all very unique very
you can't be very
you're the you are you are so it is a
unique setting sorry the parent in me
um so yes it is unique I I can't find a
reason to go again so I'm happy to
Second Council Paris proposal
but not for the holiday let I don't know
if you're being totally serious I can't
tell
um so I'll leave it there so I will
second it if that's taken out I'm
assuming that cancer Parry was being
facetious I just need to double check
because the statement you made did
include the condition
I would like to hear the officer's
response to that particular I'm not
going to waste our time with that
counselor Eden please
thank you chair um I disagree I'm afraid
um I do think that it's
not in line with admittedly a
higgledy-piggledy line of housing I do
think Limited in the film
it's definitely infill I'm not so sure
it feels limited to me personally so
that whole over development kind of feel
I think I'd probably be able to
come up with some reasons to resist but
I get the feeling they might be
I'll propose it anyway
that we refuse we'll come back to you
for reasons in just a moment now before
a council I come to council Ralph
councilor Kendall you obviously were
seconding
uh councilor parry's proposal on the
provisor that didn't include the holiday
let's are you prepared to propose yes
I'm prepared to propose that we take the
application as as set out marvelous
thank you councilor Rolf please
um I'm prepared to Second counselor Eden
here I do think it's intrusive I think
it's very tight in a tights in a tight
plot I do think it's
I don't know whether it's limited in
Phil but it's infill I do think it's out
of line and I do believe it's out of
character with the street scene
so I am happy
two second counselor Eden
okay thank you very much Council Harvey
please I should have asked this question
earlier
um
uh could the officer tell me what the
garaging arrangements are with this out
Does it include a separate garage or
integral garage
no the house would not have a garage no
garage at all
no
okay
councilor off may I ask a clarify a
question on that point
um
I understood that supplementary guidance
says that for a three-bedroom property
one should provide three parking spaces
is that correct because once again I'm
asking about parking I see that County
highways have not objected but there are
no spaces for visitors
on this plot and it is close to the road
so could you give me your opinion on the
parking
are you asking whether there's visitor
space provided
so for a three bed dwelling isbd
requires two parking spaces for the
occupiers
and with regard to visitor parking
I think on that side another car would
would fit
well I know I can see from the site plan
that another car would fit on there
anyone else before I Chuck my thoughts
in
Council yeah
I've read this and it's quite a fine
balance but I certainly impressed um
with one of the speakers the architect
um whose name I can't remember now sorry
uh Mr Simpson good first name armor and
DSR said I should remember that
um I think lots of things have covered
this this come backwards and forwards
the separation distance is the Obscure
grazing
um the PCS accepted it is limited infill
um so on on balance I will be supporting
their profession
uh thank you very much giving no one a
secondary councilor Kendall's proposal
to Grant I will do that now on the
simple basis and I do have great
sympathy with uh um uh Mr Gibson at
Malvern
um but it has been shown that the 2545
degree rule has not been breached and
separation distances are what they are
um whilst I understand his desire to
have a 13 meter separation distance
condition unfortunately we can't apply
that we can only apply that the
separation distances as set out within
the drawings can be adhered to and I'm
going to assume that that is what we
have done within our conditions we're
getting nods
um I can see no other material planning
reason to go against the office
recommendation so that's what I I am
second in cancer Kendall now we do have
a proposal to refuse and it has been
secondly so proposed by cancer and
seconded by cancer Rolfe Council Rolf
gave reasons which were predominantly uh
out of character uh in the area for the
bill line of The Wider part of of Broad
Lane did I miss anything else
I'm not sure Titan a type plot is a
planning reason but perhaps we can call
it over development
foreign
okay
so we've got three reasons there are you
happy with those
yes I am marvelous in that case could we
please have a show of hands for those uh
wishing to refuse the application for
the reason it's given
three and those against refusal
six and abstentions one that proposal
fails uh we have a proposal to Grant
secondly by myself could I have shove
hands for those if in favor of granting
in line with office recommendation
please
six and those against three and
abstentions one committee therefore
resolves two Grant application twenty
two zero three seven zero six fuel the
old Cottage and Broad Lane
um how do we have any urgent business
chat in that case I thank you all for
your help and your contributions this
evening and we will see you in a couple
of weeks the meeting is hereby closed